bonjour antoine boitel merci d'être avec
nous ce matin alors le procureur de
paris reconnaît que des policiers
devraient être mieux protégés la pénurie
de masques provoque la colère des
syndicats depuis plusieurs semaines
maintenant
quels sont les points de réconciliation
possible
bonjour oui les points de réconciliation
possible actuellement
pour le ministère de l'intérieur ce
serait de faire preuve de plus de
considération probablement pour les
agents un jour on leur dit de porter des
masques un jour on leur dit de ne pas
porter des masques
globalement on a le sentiment que ils
ont tenté de masquer un peu cette
pénurie
c'est ce que rapportent les agents de
terrain les associations de policiers en
colère aussi donc à présent on va aller
chercher notamment les policiers
technique et scientifique qui n'ont pas
réussi à bénéficier du même statut que
les policiers malgré une longue grève
on va leur demander de réaliser eux
aussi des tests de dépistage pour auprès
de la population
ces mêmes tests que les policiers
d'activ ont d'ailleurs bien du mal à
réaliser pour eux-mêmes alors qui
s'infectent les uns les autres notamment
dans des cantonnements de crs je pense à
celui de nice où s'est déplacé les crs
53 de marseille
c'est un très récemment et au sujet
duquel eric ciotti a écrit hier un
christophe castaner pour réclamer des
moyens de détection suffisant pour ces
policiers qui ensuite doivent rentrer
chez eux
potentiellement infectées eux-mêmes et
exposer leurs proches au co lead
alors malgré ses demandes 1 pour
l'instant antoine quel est l'état
d'esprit qui règne dans les forces de
l'ordre en ce moment j'ai noté pas mal
de désarroi de la colère j'en parlais
avec un crs encore très récemment
avant-hier un crs qui est qui a décidé
de rejoindre un syndicat tellement il
est en colère pour dénoncer en fait les
mesures de confinement mal mal
configurés à son sens notamment
je parle là d'un hôtel réservé aux crs à
tandoori donc le premier cantonnement de
crs de france où ils ont réservé le 7e
étage entier à tous les crs qui était
suspecté ou confirmés positifs au co
lead là il m'a dit qu'en gros lui ce
qu'il avait constaté à ses 7e étage où
il a lui-même résider c'est des gens qui
se croisent dans les couloirs des
conditions pas très sanitaires réservés
à ses collègues
voilà merci beaucoup antoine boitel pour
toutes ces précisions